[Music]
so listen to this
you don't get out of your house so this
maybe won't mean anything to you but
have you ever heard of i know timeout i
know timeout i've i've read timeout
so timeout started in the 60s you know
that it's from the 60s it's like been
around forever
and it started as like basically a
magazine and then a blog whereas like
local markets but what they're most
known for now have you ever heard of the
timeout market
no what is that okay so they do like
restaurant stuff right yes so tell me
what you know about timeout so i lived
in london and i think there i used to
pick up timeout and i lived in boulder
colorado and it's like you know if you
want to see kind of like what new
restaurants there are kind of like get
reviews of restaurants it was like
it's like your friend who's a foodie
who will like tell you what's up like oh
you got to check this place out oh it's
great this is a great place for a place
for a date and it kind of and then they
would release it at like i felt like it
a lot like maybe every week or month or
something it was like pretty frequently
updated and i think it's free right use
it for that yeah it was like free it was
just like sitting around everywhere and
i just i can visually see that red it's
like a red logo right timeout yeah so
it's a pretty timeless brand it's been
around for a long time it started in
england actually so if you live in
london it was probably most popular
there but basically in 2014 or maybe
2018 they started doing this news
concept called a timeout restaurant or a
time-out market so google time out
market and you'll see it but basically
what they do is they went into i think
the first one was in lisbon where i was
this is i went to it when i was in
lisbon but i've gone to it in miami they
have seven markets now but basically
what they did was they went to like a
touristy place and they found like the
20 most popular restaurants based off of
their blogs and like what all the
touristy stuff like oh you got to go to
portugal so you can taste the coffee
from here a croissant from here and like
some fish from here and they basically
just created um a food court like in the
middle of the city and they gave 20
restaurants different stalls and so when
you go to this different city i went to
it in miami um miami was cool because
like you know miami they say you got to
get a cubano from this place you got to
try the cuban coffee from this yeah it's
like i'm getting in a cab just to go get
the sandwich yes and so what they did
was they set it up so you can go to this
one food court and you could try all of
the famous vendors and the famous
restaurants and i went in lisbon i went
in portugal and it was awesome and it
was packed this place was packed and
time out i like you remember time out
being this like free thing and i'm like
that's kind of neat like i don't have
brand affinity towards this but when i
went this place was jammed packed with
young people and like like young hip
looking people and time out i didn't
think as a young hip brand and i started
researching this and so time out they're
publicly traded and their market cap has
been obliterated in the last three years
because a their digital media like went
to [__] because it was mostly
restaurants advertising with them and b
the way that they a lot of investors
thought that they were going to grow and
get big was through these markets which
also were basically closed down all of
2020 but they're killing it right now
this place was packed and so basically
they have 168 million market cap in 2019
they did about 70 million pounds in
revenue so what's that like is that
times two uh for dollars is that like
130. it was yeah i think i don't know if
it's still there so somewhere north but
in 2021 they only did 40 million in
revenue however 0.3 x now
uh 1.3x okay so that's they they were
doing the equivalent of over 100 million
dollars in revenue but check this out in
2019 pre-pandemic their timeout markets
did 23 million in revenue 2020 only 12
million but they only have seven
locations which means each one of these
food courts does three million in
revenue and the reason why so they have
them in lisbon miami new york boston
chicago montreal dubai and they've got
some coming up in prague and a couple
other places the reason why this is
interesting is a this is just awesome i
think this is an amazing example of a
company that has a digital media
presence that's doing a really good job
of diversifying two um
this is a really sick business because
if they're only in seven markets and
they're doing yeah you know 23 million
in revenue like there's easily a future
where you could imagine 50 or 80 of
these in
you know a variety of like you know
touristy cities it's kind of cool right
yeah this is one where the actual
experience sounds [__] awesome and so
i kind of want it to be a great business
and i bet in actuality it's like a good
business not a great one but it also
feels like something that kind of
anybody could spin up as a side hustle
um you know like if you're in durham
north carolina
there's every city has like
you know 15 20 spots that are like oh
the ice cream over here and the you know
the the sandwich over here and oh you
haven't tried the bon bons over here
whatever right like every place has
that collection of stuff and then it
becomes kind of prestigious to be picked
and all you're doing is basically making
a pop-up tent that's like a food court
but instead of you know sabaro and
cinnabon you're putting in like
cool hip places right in fact this place
should actually just have a cinnabon
every four stalls because that's what
people really want but you know besides
that you know i feel like this is a
great this is a great little side hustle
that i think anybody who's a foodie
could create um i do pretty well with i
thought it was so fun and when i went
there i was like oh this is brilliant
and so i ended up going there when i was
in portugal i wanted to go there just
like every day i'm like let's just go
like i'd rather just go here every day
taste all like a little bit of food i'll
spend ten dollars here and i wish we had
done this in miami like i would have
paid a 100 all you could eat just to
like walk through this and be able to
grab stuff you know like all you could
eat pass yes it's it's awesome and i
went to this and i realized how much fun
i had i went to i did the one in miami
too um i would i'll totally do the one
in new york but i thought this was such
an interesting basic simple concept and
they pulled it off and it was really fun
and i think that this is actually
i think it's like i don't know if this
could be an amazing business i think
that time out though they could be worth
over a billion dollars in the next two
years once they like open up right now
they're only worth 168. um
that's pounds so it's like 200 million
um stock tip i feel like we got a stock
tip here
well i'm not saying that sampar is
flashing the buy signal hard analyst sam
sampar projects time out i i want this
to get aggregated by like some random
reuters you know like you know motley
fools gonna like turn this into into a
uh article here
[Music]
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
would you buy so uh would you buy any
russian stocks right now they're getting
crushed obviously
no just because like i'm not i don't
want to make i don't want to like try to
make money off this opportunity i know
this guy okay off brand but you know i'm
on board with that i'm on board with
that but let's like let's say beyond
that let's say like let's say you're a
russian and you're actually in favor of
this war and you're just crazy and
you're in do you think that would you
have faith in the russian stock market
well a lot of these were getting close
to zero like uh you know like
like real businesses were like dropping
you know
50 70 80 percent and so yeah you know
you're getting tremendous value so if
you're a citizen there and you're a
believer and
you know you don't want to be in the
local currency anyway so you need to
you'd rather if you just told me you can
either stay in the ruble or you can take
your ruble and turn it into something
else i'm gonna always take something
else and their options on something else
got cut off like okay you can't get
dollars you can't get crypto you can't
get can get different things so what are
you gonna buy
and um
you know so because they were limited in
many ways across those some like there
was like you know they stopped the
amount of rubles you could sell and so
you know if you could get into stocks
hey it's better than better than staying
in in the uh in the paper
yeah it's interesting i i wouldn't buy a
russian company just for the same
reasons that you said but we did the
episode in the oligarchs and that was
like a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
where russia was going from communist to
somewhat capitalist and in my head i'm
like
this might be another one of those
opportunities where you could like buy
like the equivalent of exxon in russia
which hopefully likely won't go or i
don't care about hopefully but it likely
won't go away but you could get like a
huge discount
all right um
i got a couple of things for you but
first did you see this thing about the
right wing site that went viral which
one uh okay so check out this i wrote
this thing on the on our job right-wing
side goes viral it's a link to a tweet
so this guy jed legume which is just a
got to be a fake name
judd legume he says a far-right website
launched 36 days ago and it's already
more popular on facebook than the
washington post
the dc inquirer has executed an
audacious scheme to manipulate
facebook's algorithm and ad platform and
meta is letting them get away with it
and so basically
the article talks about um
this publication that was created so let
me uh
um it's called the dc enquirer
and they'll have articles that are like
you know
um
you know like whatever the freedom
convoy is on the verge of victory in
canadian provinces right and they will
get a bunch of people to post about it
and what they showed was that um
and so they so they got like all these
right-wing pages that are like impeach
joe biden or i love america keep texas
red uh save america and they were all
posting the same thing
and so that should be kind of like a
it's basically like a coordinated kind
of like ad campaign or whatever
and it started to get really really big
so the page um this guy brandon gill
created the page and
you know it has like i don't know over a
million um you know like a million
followers or something like very quickly
and it's all run under this like uh
yeah it's basically like this this
right-wing thing that got popular now
you've told me about this before which
is that cons extremely conservative or
extremely liberal sites will get very
popular very quickly especially on
facebook but and i was pretty uh
surprised to see this yeah there's a
butt here
liberals like yeah obviously polarized
on one side does well
conservative
does
significantly better
because this is a principle that is
always true which is a group of people
that feel downtrodden like feel like
they're underdog they band together and
they get in an outrage does more for
sharing and in america so there's like
groups like minorities women um a lot of
like far right conservatives because
media is typically left they think you
know our voice is being stomped out and
so they band together so if you go to
huffpo and you go and look at the
comments section and then go to
breitbart and look at how many comments
if you go have you been to breitbart.com
yeah i've been there go to breitbart and
just like click a random article and
look how many comments sometimes it's 20
000 comments it's crazy so i totally
believe it with this website and i'm by
the way i'm looking up um dc and choir i
googled it i don't see a website is it
literally just a
so so basically it looks like what he's
done he's basically created like a web
of
like accounts that are kind of all the
same so so basically it's like there's
the guy's personal account it's got
brandon gill
and his bio is like you know i'm the
founder and editor of
dcenquirer.com so that's the that's the
url uh dc inquirer with a to e e n q
um
and it's like his bio is patriot period
proud west texan period businessman
financer rancher conservative christian
dartmouth husband
it's like
bingo you know you get you hit all the
words congratulations
by the way sam you are also a rancher
you're almost like a husband
i like most all those things
is he also a fan of fan of corn dogs
this guy's like
[Laughter]
so then he's got like basically a whole
bunch of other pages so i think red wave
i love america all those pages i
mentioned i think those are his pages so
they've all been built up like ones at a
million one's at six hundred fifty
thousand one's at two hundred thousand
and he's running ads that were are like
if you go look at brandon gill's ads in
the ad library uh so if you've never
done this before by the way it's like
one of the best tools available to any
internet person is
if you go to facebook.com and then you
are just google facebook ad library and
then you can look up the ads of any
brand what ads they're running so if you
look at the brands he's running it'll be
like a picture of joe biden is like
talking at a rally like kind of
confronting somebody and it says if you
want joe biden removed from office tap
the big thumbs up in the right corner
and so it's like you know it's clearly
like running political ads that are not
marked as political ads basically so
this guy's point was like oh they're
he's getting away with it you know
facebook you know you need to shut this
down what i thought was interesting was
dude this would be an amazing little
prank like if i'm mischief or i'm just
like someone out there with like a
[__] with too much time on their
hands here's what i would do
i'd basically do the same thing i'd make
a extremely
conservative site
and i would put out some articles i
would get the traction and i would do
this for like two months
and then the third month i would just
pull the rug on everybody and it would
just switch to an extremely
liberal lgbtq website with the same
email list
i'll just switch everything overnight
once i get all these people subscribed
which just for sure
would make the news um yeah then and
then that story of the prank pulled
would create a new cycle of its own
and then you could basically go get any
job you want in any marketing pr or
whatever agency because you could be
like yeah i just i did this like so
instead of sending your resume out and
cover letter like do a stunt that shows
your knowledge of how the internet works
how media works how pr works how
marketing works and
you know you'll impress a lot of people
with your ability to like pull off a
stunt like that that's actually how
buzzfeed started too uh was jonah
peretti was pulling stunts like this i
think he did it with nike nike yeah what
was it again i don't remember exactly
but he uh basically said he revealed
like a a fake easter egg so he said like
i think it was like if you
do something with this pair of shoes
something happens something like no no
no no no it was it was an email thing it
was like a sweatshop thing okay so
here's what it is oh so he goes to nike
had this feature personalized id where
you could like write your name i don't
know if you did this i did this i got my
name yeah yeah on my shoes i thought it
was so cool he goes
so he writes an email
uh you know from from jonah peretti to
nike id personalize nike.com he goes
greetings my order was cancelled because
my personal nike id does not
but my oh no my order was canceled but
my nike id does not violate any of the
outlined uh rules um in your message
so
the personal id on my custom shoes was
the word sweatshop sweatshop is not a
name of another party's trademark the
name of an athlete blank or profanity i
chose the id because i wanted to
remember the toilet and labor of the
children that made my shoes could you
please ship them to me immediately
thanks and happy new year jonah pereira
and so then he
sent that obviously that's not going to
go viral as an email but he screenshots
that and started getting it and put it
out there and then that got like kind of
like a big news storm uh going and he
was doing stunts like this before
creating buzzfeed and it kind of showed
this guy knows how to make the internet
you know how to tickle the internet and
he uh he he did it well one of my
favorite things to watch on youtube is
these videos where people will do one of
two things they'll go it's usually
always political stuff and they go to
someone and they say
isn't this outrageous this person said
this thing and they'll read what they
personally said and go do you don't
agree with that do you and they go oh no
i don't agree with that at all like i'm
a conservative there's no way i would be
like oh well this is what donald trump
said uh or like you know like they'll do
something like that well they'll like
make you disagree with something that
you whatever and then they'll do or
they'll do it and they'll say do you
agree with this and they'll read out
like um a speech from hitler and they're
like yeah i totally agree with that i'm
like oh hitler said so it's not it's
it's and it's actually not that fair to
do that but well they also go to 100
people and 96 have like a normal
reaction and then the four that
fall for it it's like they stitch those
together and it just makes it look like
everybody at this trump rally feel is
dumb and makes this mistake and it's
like they kind of make new yorkers or
rally you know participants or teens or
millennials on college campuses they'll
make them look like idiots because
they'll right all you got to do is you
talk to enough people you're going to
catch five people who fall for the the
trick right it's like borat right like
uh when he does these tricks or these
stunts they do go viral and they do make
you know the other party look bad but
they don't show you all the people that
didn't fall for it and don't believe
that and didn't say something stupid in
response
[Music]